would there be a movie that you would be
like I'd revisit that they've got a cool
idea with it like would you revisit uh
the one about the uh you know uh Ido Edy
Falco yeah 100% like there's I think all
of the the roles I've done if they were
over like would you want to revisit
there's not one role I've done where I'm
like I never want to play that again you
know what I mean not one and I think the
I've always had this lipus test and it
served me well when I take on a role I
always think to myself am am I going to
be excited on my ride to work and that's
the litest I have for like saying yes I
say the same element of fun yeah because
because if I have the passion on the way
to work and I'm excited on the way to
work I know I'm going to put everything
I have into it and then I can't control
if the movie does well the TV show does
well but but when I look back and
someone's like what was your favorite
thing you've ever done I can honestly
say all of them because I've had the
same level of passion on the ride to
work for each and every one of them so
if someone's like hey would you would
you want to revisit that role yeah cuz I
had fun doing it you know what I mean
even if it was like I've done one that's
for seven years like I had honestly had
fun going to work every day even the
Vampire movie yeah you would do it in a
heartbeat in a heartbeat I mean I'm
probably too old to play now cuz like
vampires don't age but uh you can age if
you want to can you n vampir if you
don't drink enough blood and you get
older and then you drink blood no I
think I they can change the around
could I think they could I think you
look good oh thank you man it's all in
the eyes yeah